pour lutter contre la fraude la sncf
utilise désormais une nouvelle technique
à bord de ses trains
des agents de contrôle en civil et on
l'a vu ça dans le trésor de proches de
pasqua
en jeans et baskets dans la rame il
pastina perçu à nancy depuis le mois
d'octobre quatre contrôleurs sncf
circule dans les wagons en civil pour
détecter les fraudeurs en complément des
agents en uniforme et cela ne semble pas
gêner les usagers
pour moi c'est tout à fait normal la
dernière minute à la première minute
mais on est dans le train en bénéficient
des services sont plus des patrouilles
effectuées quatre à cinq fois par mois
une nouvelle stratégie pour tenter de
réduire de 30% la fraude d'ici 2020 car
en lorraine les fraudeurs coûte cher à
la sncf
ça représente entre 8 et 10 millions
d'euros de manque à gagner pour sncf
c'est l'équivalent d'une rame ter part
en retraite qui peut pas être acheté 200
milles alors le montant annuel caroline
ithurbide de la fraude s'élève à 300
millions d'euros soit l'achat de dirhams
qu'est-ce qui se passe alors est ce que
vous trouvez que la nouvelle technique
pour lutter contre la fraude avec ses
agents en civil qui au dernier moment
mettre le brassard et d'istres à pied
s'il vous plaît contrôler s'il vous
plaît ticket s'il vous plaît qu'est ce
que vous en pensez caroline atroce
commencé à suivre pid inutile rapporte
de l'âge non relâche pour les fraudeurs
randall actionnaires je suis scandalisée
je ne comprends pas pourquoi ils ont
besoin de se cacher pour brasser pour
choper une fois je vais pas non plus
raté par la fenêtre en plein les yeux si
vous voulez mon avis je me fais gaulle
et je me fais gaulle et j'ai au moins
l'honnêteté de reconnaître quand je me
fais choper que j'ai frauder bon allez à
ce moment là je paye mon je paye mon
amende mais ils le savent s'ils
voulaient si vous les voyez sur le quai
vous dites je vais aller prendre mon
petit clic et vous les voyez pas alors
qu'ils sont en blouson machin acceptera
qui monte en même temps que vous et
qu'ensuite ils mettent le brassard c'est
la paire malhonnête a la base je sais
elle est malhonnête
non mais là vers l extraordinaire des
contrôleurs je sais qu'il ya des
contrôleurs sages auront on le sait
depuis la nuit des temps il ya des
contrôleurs qui sera pour contrôler les
billets donc moi j'ai deux petites
annonces avec tambours et trompettes
on est sur lequel on a l'habitude déjà
je pense que ce serait beaucoup plus
efficace plutôt de faire une sorte de
chasse aux sorcières ignoble et en plus
je trouve qu'il ne s'attaque pas à la
vraie cause c'est à dire que s'il ya
autant de fraudes c'est peut-être aussi
parce que nous en tant que usagers on a
été abusé c'est ce qu'avait papa l'avait
sont pas à la tire ou des trains qui
partent toujours effectivement au bout
d'un moment alors on est tous fatigués
je dois dire caroline que venance vous
bon légitimer la fraude je m'attendais
évidemment un passage de vous oui mais
de jimmy mohamed qui vient visiblement
est énervé c'est un scandale
mais je vous croyais droit comme la
justice non mais c'est une technique de
race c'est comme les contrôleurs la ratp
dans le métro la crise cache derrière un
couloir avant et rita pied dans votre
titre de transport monsieur ils sont
contents de mettre des amendes
moi je le vois la satisfaction sur le
visage rendez vous avez fraude et non je
suis désolé
franchement ça c'est minable parce que
en fait le problème en france c'est que
on prend les transports en commun y'a
aucun contrôle mais finalement on incite
les gens à frauder parce que quand on
écoute et andy fickman nature que si on
a tendance dans le nord cette fois on a
finalement on enlevait les moyens
humains pour faire des économies partout
dans le monde où j'ai pu voyager à
chaque fois il ya des policiers
il ya un contrôleur qui fait que même où
quelqu'un au guichet les gens au guichet
n'existe plus et forcément on les voit
aussi maintenant effectivement on va
payer et là on incite les gens à fodé et
puis finalement on nous dit non
attention ça va couler émanation de la
million d'euros eh ben ça coûte 300
millions d'euros
et ben moi je règle le problème du
chômage en france engagé des contrôleurs
vous allez voir le chômage diminuer des
gens avant retard avant l'émergence des
meilleurs vous étiez un peu de mauvaise
foi pardon il faudrait qu'il y ait un
guichet un guichetier un contrôleur soit
pas visible et et et je ne puis qui
derrière vous la peur du gendarme pour
que vous payez alors que normalement
vous devez poser en sac ou 300 millions
d'euros donc il ya une façon de
récupérer de l'argent cette femme s'est
créé de l'emploi s'améliorait décodage à
l'étude autant vous vous êtes parti en
vrac
c'est un d'avoir moi ce que je conteste
dans cette méthode c'est le fait de se
cacher pour avoir un contrôle et le
contrôle dans le train c'est quelque
chose de normal
à la limite c'est préventif ça veut dire
mettre des contrôleurs on sait qu'il ya
des contrôleurs on va pas triché après
se cacher pour essayer de ses presque
pervers de faire ça pour essayer de
choper les gens ça je suis pas d'accord
mais par contre contrôler c'est quand
même normal
d'ailleurs vous avez contenance une ou
les deux en fait vous vous battez comme
ça parce que vous êtes dans l'esprit des
fraudeurs mais ils se cachent pas ils ne
s'annonce pas c'est pas la même chose
quand les gendarmes sont sur la route et
sont dans les fourrés et qu'il vous
arrête parce que vous allez trop vite
wattez contre ils y pensent chandail
elle aime les gamines dans les forêts la
fraude et surtout que bon il ya certains
métiers ou caroline se plaindrait pas si
un joli médecin qui était beau qui
sentait bon venaient sonner chez elle à
l'ouvré à la porte je ne vois pas que
c'est un médecin mettez vous sur le lit
déshabillez vous petite visite une
écologie n'ait pas pu mais oui mais
alors lâchez moi vous savez ce qu'on va
faire
non on tout à l'heure on m'a recruté
vous m'expliquerez le raisonnement qui
les a fait partir des contrôles aux
gynécologues
[Applaudissements]
les contrôleurs toute évidence pour une
écoute une bonne idée parce que c'est
scandaleux c'est une bonne idée
messieurs les fraudeurs à 64% scandaleux
pour 36% regarder comment ça marche bien
les contrôles en civil [ __ ] j'allais
tranquille à porte maillot et aller
contre l'eire la balle à la [ __ ] je
peux même pas avancer j'ai pas tiqué
chargé de faire demi tour
on sort à vous êtes contre l'eire ok
[Applaudissements]
c'était caroline mécary noël au narco
état reconnu qu'un os